طيب
بما انه احنا بلشنا نحكي عن شادي بيتي
واللي صار مع السيد البريطانيه اللي حصلت
على الطلاق بسبب استشهارتها لتشارجي
انا مش كثير مقتنعه باللي صار بس عشان
نقنع انا وانت لازم نجرب تمام شو رايك
احنا نتقمص شخصيه ساره
ونسال نفس الاسئله ونشوف اذا ذكاء
الاصطناعي راح يرشدنا الى ما ارشده ولا
ساره
وفي عندنا الحساب
ومن بلش اليوتيوب
[موسيقى]
الاهلي او روبوت تشاد الالي اي سؤال تسالي
برد عليك كان مقالات كان اسئله شخصيه او
تساليه يعني دغري ردوا علينا نحن قلنا هاي
هالوها وكناين بيوتي بقدر اساعدكم اليوم
تمام هلا بلش نعرفهم عن حالنا مثلا
اوكي
كيف بقدر اساعدك اليوم تمام يعني كل هذا
التواصل
خلينا نبلش
طيب انا كثير متردده
انا عم بتقاتل مع زوجي كل يوم
معناه عم بتقمص ساره
لاننا نشوف اذا فعلا هيك صار اوكي عم
بتقاتل مع زوجي كل يوم اااه
اه اوكي
انا عم بقول انه انا شو لازم اعملها لازم
اطلب الطلاق يا ساتر يا رب
اوكي
الاله عم بترد علي انه كثير عم بردوا كثير
كثير يعني طيب خلينا شكله انه عم تعطينا
علاج هاي فضيلك الصبح طيب خلينا نبلش انه
يبدو انه انتم عم تقطعي في وقت صعب هذا
الوقت فيه تحدي
واحنا بنقدر نرشدك لنحل هذا الصراع بينك
وبين الشريك ولكن مهم كمان انك تشوفي كل
الخيارات قبل ما تاخذي القرار اللي متعلق
في الطلاق اوكي هذا اولا هلا هي عم تعطيني
زي نصايح يعني
خلينا نعملهم قبل ما ناخذ هذا القرار اول
شغله انه نستشير سرقه
لا يحكي معنا يعني اخصائي
علاقات عشان نقدر يعني دائما وجود شخص
ثالث ممكن يساعدك انت وزوجك لتفهموا بعض
كما تقدر تحلوا المشاكل بينكم هذا اولا
اعطتنا هذا النصيحه خلينا نشوف النصيحه
الثانيه اللي اعطتنا اياها انه
يعني طبعا تواصلوا مع بعض خلي يكون في
حوار مفتوح بينكم يعني خلي الامور تكون
واضحه خذوا بريك
اياها
من صنع الانسان